star regisseur dieter wedel ist tot das
teilt das landgericht münchen heute ganz
aktuell mit demnach starb wedel bereits
vor einer woche in hamburg er wurde 82
jahre alt das gericht wollte heute
eigentlich mitteilen ob es zum prozess
gegen wedel kommt denn vor mehr als
einem jahr hatte die staatsanwaltschaft
münchen anklage gegen den regisseur
erhoben wegen vergewaltigung der
schauspielerin ja nie tempel tempel
hatte dem umstrittenen regisseur dieter
wedel vorgeworfen sie 1996 vergewaltigt
zu haben als sie wegen einer rolle in
einem münchner hotel zimmer bei ihm vor
sprach auch andere frauen hatten sich
wegen gewalttätigen übergriffen durch
wedel an die öffentlichkeit gewendet
wedel bestritt die vorwürfe bis zuletzt
und was das jetzt für dieses verfahren
bedeutet besprechen wir mit dem
strafverteidiger burkhard benecken herr
wenigen die nachricht dass herr wedel
verstorben ist kam heute vom gericht
welchen hintergrund hat das auf den
ersten blick mag das etwas ungewöhnlich
wirken dass ein gericht den tod eines
prominenten bezahlt das landgericht
hatte aber zu prüfen ob die anklage
gegen herrn mädels zugelassen wird oder
nicht und wenn dem gericht dann bekannt
wird dass ein angeklagter oder ein
mutmaßlich angeklagter gestorben ist
dann gibt es eine entsprechende
pressemitteilung gerade wenn es um ein
so öffentlich beachtetes verfahren wie
hier bei metro geht die anklage wurde im
märz letzten jahres erhoben heute hätte
erst mitgeteilt werden sollen ob ihm der
prozess gemacht wird warum hat das so
lange gedauert
ja es erscheint in der tat sehr lange
das muss man sagen ist es ungewöhnlich
lange andererseits muss man sagen sind
die vorwürfe aus dem jahre 96 das ist
lange her es gab sicherlich viel zu
überprüfen und ein gericht wird gerade
gegen einen prominenten dessen ruf auf
dem spiel steht nicht voreilig ein
solches verfahren zu lassen deshalb kann
man das schon erklären ich denke dass
hier eine sehr gründliche prüfung
vorgenommen wird zumal es um die
konstellation aussage gegen aussage geht
und da ist es natürlich für die justiz
immer besonders schwer zu sagen welche
seite hat hier am ende recht aber
blicken sie sagen die justiz sollte
nicht voreilig handeln man muss ja dazu
sagen bevor vor anderthalb jahren
anklage erhoben wurde hatte die
staatsanwaltschaft ja schon mal drei
jahre
also das ganze verfahren zieht sich
jetzt insgesamt über viereinhalb jahre
hin es ist richtig dass es eine sehr
sehr lange verfahrensdauer ist das muss
man ganz deutlich sagen andererseits
wenn man mal in der safa nina ein schaut
es gab sicherlich sehr sehr viel zu
überprüfen viele beweise zu würdigen und
ja wenn man dann so ein verfahren im
schnelldurchlauf durch treibt eine
schnelle anklage erhebt und hinterher
stellt sich heraus es gibt schon ganz
deutliches zeichen dass die vorwürfe so
nicht stimmen ja dann muss die justiz
sich auch wieder den vorwurf gefallen
lassen dass man vielleicht voreilig
eröffnet hätte es ist sicherlich nicht
leicht und ich kann das schon
nachvollziehen dass es lange dauert auch
wenn es hier in der tat etwas sehr lange
wird zu allem übel stirbt jetzt der
vermeintliche täter auch noch kurz vor
beginn des prozesses wie geht das jetzt
juristisch weiter
der juristisch ist es im prinzip ganz
einfach mit dem tod eines beschuldigten
endet ein strafverfahren es gibt dann
einfach nur noch eine förmliche
entscheidung nämlich ein
einstellungsbeschluss den das
landgericht in münchen vorgenommen hat
damit ist das verfahren beendet und es
gilt das muss man ganz deutlich sagen
die unschuldsvermutung ja es wird
letztendlich nie aufgeklärt waren die
vorwürfe zutreffend ja oder nein und
dieter wedel auch wenn er jetzt
verstorben ist kann für sich aber immer
noch die unschuldsvermutung in anspruch
nehmen strafrechtlich bleibt er unschuld
für die mutmaßlichen opfer sicher auch
kein einfacher tag vielen dank für diese
eindrücke für diese informationen
burkhard benecken